she is just one of the best
actors i've ever worked with she is so
good
she is on it her acting is just
impeccable
and i can see why she does not stop
working
it was a character and a movie that i
don't really get the opportunity to play
so i was really excited and then when i
found out kevin
james was involved and i was super
excited because an action thriller with
a
14 year old female as a lead and then
kevin james is the villain
sounds like my perfect dream project
jeff this gentleman lost his dog okay
well why don't you give us your number a
dog is a rottweiler
purebred what does the germans call them
violent
that's why you never let the mate with
other breeds you get the worst of both
okay i think it's time for you to go the
action thriller follows a teenager named
becky whose weekend with her father and
his fiance
takes a turn for the worse when a group
of convicts led by kevin james invade
i think sometimes people go oh comedians
it must be a real departure for you
but before i was doing any comedy that
was known to people i was doing tons of
plays that were
serious and not funny and so i counted
as kind of like i get
to do more uh something else stay calm
i'm looking for a key it has this symbol
engraved on it
you seen it no kevin james is great to
work with he was
incredibly nice he was very funny of
course he was also playing a very scary
character
and in those moments when we had to kind
of do intense scenes then
that we weren't funny for amanda the
shoot location helped make the film
extra special
it's great because i get to fly home
every night to my kids
um we're shooting actually just outside
of toronto and you know i really love
being able to go outside of hollywood
north and be able to see just how
beautiful
canada is the best part about shooting
outside of toronto has been
enjoying the changing landscape as i
travel from set to home